[Music]
up next is gonna be chris in los angeles
hi chris welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave how are you doing great man
what's up
um there's a couple things one you uh
you've done some great work and in some
ways i love you
in other ways you're stupid and arrogant
okay
how can i help you all right by the way
that's a great way to start any
conversation right there
yeah well
my first question would be are you
smarter than warren buffett
how old are you
because you push i'm 35 okay cool
so what i'm sorry
let's stop just a second what's the
point of your call how can i help you
the the point of my call is you push
people into actively managed funds
when over time
if you push people into an index fund
they would have
about 50 percent more money when they
return
okay
um not sure where you went to school for
your math class
but you failed
um
the uh actually compounding cost i i i
understand add up dramatically i've been
t i got socks older than you i've been
teaching this a while okay
so uh
this is how this works now here's the
thing you're basically become doing what
bogle said and bogle invented a
wonderful thing with the index fund and
the s p 500 funds are wonderful the
index funds are wonderful
they are not a cure-all and there is no
possible scenario unless you're an
absolute idiot in picking your actively
managed funds that you would have 50
percent more
in an index fund now the actual facts
are
more than 50 of the funds under perform
the indexes
that is a true fact to your point that's
a different fact
the fact is two percent two percent
above if if you have a seven percent
return versus a nine percent return
which you have the compounding cost
bringing your return down by two percent
over 50 years you'll have half the money
do the math on that google it that that
would be true too but none of those
numbers you're using are accurate in
terms of what the s p has produced or
what actively managed funds are produced
the actively managed funds that i
personally have picked have outperformed
the indexes by more than two percent as
a portfolio because it's fairly easy to
study mutual funds and pick them that
outperform but if you're not going to
study them and you're not going to have
a good advisor in your corner then using
the index funds is a great idea here's
what we actually found in the real world
versus
versus someone's
hypothetical vacuum discussion of theory
okay as we studied the largest study of
millionaires
90 percent of them a larger study of
millionaires ever done over 10 000 of
them 90 of them became wealthy without
becoming without inheritance the
inheritance did not cause their wealth
and almost all and almost all of them
did it with their 401k with actively
managed funds now some of the funds
actually underperformed the s p
and some of them overperformed the s p
and some of them used an s p because
a good 500 fund was in there
what was in their portfolio as well now
let's go back to warren buffett for just
a second are you aware that warren
buffett does not have all of his
investments in index funds
of course
i'm not sure other than the fact that he
has stated that the average guy because
he's a bogolite the average guy should
buy index funds instead of actively
managed funds other than that he doesn't
actually do what he says he's going to
do with that he actually has an actively
managed portfolio called berkshire
hathaway are you aware of that
yes i am and he's doing it with with the
money he's leaving through his life when
he dies well that's fine i mean where
the money's going is not not relevant to
the mathematical discussion the
mathematical discussion chris is simply
this warren buffett made comments
frequently about the average guy should
buy index funds and i really don't have
a problem with that you can get rich
with index funds
not 50 percent richer that's complete bs
but you know that is true but if you but
you can get rich with index funds i
don't have any problem with that at all
if that makes me arrogant fine but i
think we're confused as to who's
arrogant on this call brother
i think that's the issue i've got a book
suggestion for chris it's called how to
win friends and influence people it's a
classic you should read it
no
i mean it's
good luck with it i hope it works out
for you but um
here's the thing
i've been doing what i've done doing for
30 years chris and it's made me a multi
multi multi multi millionaire and i
invest in actively managed growth stock
mutual funds that outperform the indexes
across the four types we teach i
actually invest in what i tell people to
do
i don't tell people to do something
while i'm investing in something else
different than my friend warren
this is the ramsey show